I have enormous respect and gratitude  toward us as everyone does for the  incredible job they do and like I know  things are difficult right now for  everyone because of what's happening  with inflation and that's why our plans  that we outlined last week will get a  group of inflation and bring it down  that's really important and in the  meantime what what the unions are asking  for I think is a 19 pay rise and I think  most people watching will recognize that  that's obviously unaffordable and that's  why I'm pleased that the health  secretary is sitting down talking to the  union and hopefully we can find a way  through this